♪♪
Man:
Tails on A, B mark.
(Clap)
Man:
Ready... and action.
(Engine revving)
♪♪
(Jeff beeping)
(Fan motor)
♪♪
(Engine revving)
Miguel Sapochnik:
I like world creation.
I think as world building, it’s
really interesting but the idea was
making a family movie that has a
dark, quirky edge to it.
Storm alarm:
Warning, shelter advised.
(Wind blowing)
Finch:
Here we go!
(High-pitched ringing)
Miguel’s vision is extremely
sharp and not intimidated by
tough themes,
Tom Hanks:
difficult shooting schedules,
or incredibly complicated
effects shots.
(Wind meter)
The project originated with
Miguel Sapochnik, the director,
Kevin Misher:
who had developed it with the
writers, Ivor Powell and Craig Luck.
Kevin Misher:
Craig had actually started it as
a short story
Kevin Misher:
and they partnered to write the
script and brought it to Miguel.
Craig Luck:
Miguel, as a director,
is an incredible visionary
because his visual style fit an
epic movie so perfectly.
Ivor Powell:
When the movie begins, it’s ten
years after this post-apocalyptic event,
and we wanted to try and do
something that was literally
focused on the
Ivor Powell:
relationship between the
characters.
(Door opening)
(Goodyear Barking)
Finch is an engineer and a
computer scientist
Tom Hanks:
and a developer of software
and as far as his part of the
world, he’s the only guy left.
(Strong winds)
Tom Hanks:
We’re in a facility that
operated at a sound stage,
Tom Hanks:
but when Finch has to escape
from this part of the world,
then everything else that was
outdoors we shot literally, you
know, outdoors.
♪♪
Tom Hanks:
So he has this escape vehicle
that he’s slowly been putting
together and they gotta pile
into the family RV and take off.
Tom Meyer:
When we’re trying to create a
world for these characters to exist in,
Tom Meyer:
the RV is a central character.
We spend maybe fifty, sixty
percent of the film on a road
trip.
Tom Meyer:
It’s something they can live in,
it has a little kitchen,
Tom Meyer:
and if I jack it up and I put it
on big old monster truck wheels,
Tom Meyer:
then I’m gonna roll over any
obstacle I can.
(Crashing)
(Bang)
(Heavy winds)
(Heavy breathing)
We had fireman suits, and hazmat
suits, and all different kinds
of
Bart:
outdoor boots and gloves and
helmets and goggles,
Bart:
and it was cool to see Tom think
about what would Finch do with this stuff.
I had a lot of costume fittings
and meetings, and
I was very glad to be in my
ultraviolet protection suit
there
Tom Hanks:
because everybody else was just
wind burned.
Tom Hanks:
And I kinda got to sit inside
with an air conditioned helmet even when we were outside.
When Tom puts it on, it almost
instantly feels iconic.
♪♪
Get your elbows off the table.
Seamus, who is the acting dog
that plays Goodyear,
I mean, he’s just an award
winner as far as charm goes.
Miguel Sapochnik:
Letting him do his own thing
gets you far more interesting stuff,
and then he also has these great
eyebrows.
Miguel Sapochnik:
So anytime he kind of raises his
eyebrow in one direction, it feels like a really big thing.
Jacqueline Levine:
We hired the best dog trainer in
the business in Mark Forbes,
and we basically auditioned a
bunch of dogs.
Jacqueline Levine:
We narrowed it down to two of
our favorite dogs
Jacqueline Levine:
and then we had Tom Hanks come
in and help us decide on Seamus.
Seamus had verve.
Tom Hanks
He carried with him a type of
mysterious gravitas.
The projection, I think, that
comes along with a man and his
dog, in this case,
Tom Hanks:
is that the audience begins to
supply Seamus’ dialogue.
Alright, you’re next.
(Dog whimper)
Finch:
Come here, dog breath.
(Goodyear growling)
Finch: Come here.
Tom Hanks:
They begin to understand what,
in this case, Goodyear is
thinking and what his responses
are to it.
Ooooh... where’s your ball?
Is it here?
Tom Hanks:
I like to think that, as the
actor,
Tom Hanks:
I bring a number of goods to the
mix.
Tom Hanks:
Caleb, as Jeff, brings a
substantial amount of elements to it that I cannot provide.
Tom Hanks:
And what was missing from the
movie, from the two of us, Seamus provided.
Now it is a classic triangle of
lifeforms.
Tom Hanks:
It is the canine lifeform, the
human lifeform,
Tom Hanks:
and Caleb Landry Jones as Jeff,
this robot, this companion, actually.
(Bang)
Jeff:
Would you like me to drive?
No, you just learned how to
walk.
On this movie, we’re introduced
to the project by Tom Meyer, the
production designer,
Lindsay MacGowan:
who came up with the designs for
Dewey and for Jeff.
Lindsay MacGowan:
Dewey is a much simpler
character.
Lindsay MacGowan:
Jeff is really Finch, and he
learns throughout the whole movie how to become a man,
Lindsay MacGowan:
whereas Dewey will always only
ever be this character that can’t really emote.
(Crashes)
Jeff is really a great design
and something that was ground in
the real world.
Lindsay MacGowan:
So his head is the top of a
welding gas tank.
Lindsay MacGowan:
A lot of his body parts are from
finding things that you'd use in a real workshop.
Lindsay MacGowan:
Jeff is six foot, six inches
tall so we created stilts
Lindsay MacGowan:
so the interesting part of
the performance of Jeff is the gait of the walk.
We got so used to working with
Caleb,
Miguel Sapochnik:
and we used mo-cap, a
movement suit, that records his movements.
Miguel Sapochnik:
That’s been a really interesting
and experimental thing.
And one of the other things that
Miguel told me
Tom Meyer:
when we were designing Jeff is:
can opener, right in his chest,
Tom Meyer:
right where his heart needs to
be.
Tom Meyer:
His heart is the well-being of
the dog.
These robots take on a certain
humanity that
Lindsay MacGowan:
other robots in the past
certainly don’t seem to have had.
Lindsay MacGowan:
And I think you get that from
the performance of puppeteers,
Lindsay MacGowan:
Caleb and CG Jeff.
Storm alarm:
Tornado detection, shelter
advised.
♪♪
It was so windy that day,
Tom Hanks:
that we had wind machines that
lay unused
Tom Hanks:
because we had about a fifty to
sixty mile an hour wind that was blowin’ all the sand.
The great thing about CGI now,
Tom Hanks:
is you can do anything, and I
didn’t remember Caleb in costume.
Tom Hanks:
I was just seeing Jeff as Jeff.
Finch:
Get back in here!
What we have to create with
visual effects is
Scott Stokdyk:
the artificial intelligence
robot based on Caleb’s performance
Scott Stokdyk:
and kind of give the world a
taste of the promise of what future technology is,
Scott Stokdyk:
but then have this really
dark world that’s very hard to survive in.
(Jeff barking)
(Goodyear barking)
-Finch: Hey! Hey!
What’s all the fuss?
Jeff:
I learned to talk dog.
(Dewey beeping)
The beautiful thing that the
film does,
Tom Hanks:
that I think the audience
recognizes,
Tom Hanks:
is that, it is not human to be
alone.
Tom Hanks:
It is not human to be a solo
being.
Tom Hanks:
We must have company
because in company, we find
companionship,
Tom Hanks:
we find love.
That’s the high country, man,
Tom Hanks:
when you can capture that on
film.
♪♪